good to see you Alec you too yeah you
look so good doesn't he look good no
wonder you I know I know I just get to
look at that you know still feel about
section oh absolutely you know when you
longer now when you first came on our
show this is years and years and years
ago back in the 90s at NBC you the first
thing you said is you sensed a sexual
tension between Andy rector and myself
the sexual tension between you and Andy
is even thicker now when I use that word
specifically we're both thicker yeah so
you really I'm doing great yeah I'm
doing great you know uh it's uh it's
been you know we see more often when I
was in New York obviously we died now
I'm here and pain in the ass to get out
here I gotta say it's a family yeah it
was good
we sent a car they drove you like we're
doing in Saskatchewan Los Angeles that
we talked about this you know you lived
in New York for many years I live in New
York I had a house out here back and
forth for years but my wife wants to
maybe move out here you know she's very
loves the weather and she does a good
bit of whining about the winter in New
York now with our kids and I was asking
you if now that you've been here blown
yeah you've adjusted to it you have you
said I think I have yeah it's a big
adjustment you first get out here but
there's a lot of things I like about Los
Angeles and it's actually I think the
culture here is getting better and
better all the time it's there's a lot
going on in LA when you're a famous
comic like you yeah comic performer like
what do you do when you want to get out
of the house - you like lie to your wife
and say you're going to Vegas to perform
for the weekend or like what do you do
to like make ups like show it's exactly
what I say I say I got a I say I got a
big show in Vegas it seizes I gotta get
out of here
and then I go to the local Ramada Inn
and I just sit there with my phone oh
yeah in downtown LA and I just drink and
watch Judge Judy you know
[Laughter]
you